j'ouvre notre second débat c'est un
droit de suite que je vous propose 3
semaines après les crues qui ont frappé
le Pas de Calais dans des communes déjà
inondées début novembre comment l'État
vient-il en aide aux habitants le modèle
économique des assureurs peut-il tenir
dans ce contexte de catastrophe à
répétition faut-il condamner raser
certains quartiers inondables comment si
c'est fait venir en aide à celles et
ceux qui habite avant de répondre à ces
questions reportage reportage signé
Fabien Recker dans les rues d' c'est
l'une des villes les plus sinistré dans
le département du pcal en l'assablement
il faut nettoyer les trottoirs voilà des
semaines que les agents de la commune
d'Arc sont mobilisés partout en ville
cétat d'encombrant tout ce qu'il reste à
vider des maisons sinistré les gens
après une fois que les experts sont
passés mettent devant chez eux et nous
on passe avec les camions pour évacuer
tout ce qu'ils ont à jeter en fait l'eau
elle avait monté jusque ici donc les
habitants de ces appartements ont été
bloqués chez eux en fait des habitants
excédés qui parfois perdent patience
Mang par là ah oui je vous comprends
monsieurci ça sert à rien ce qui là-bas
il va salir oui je vous comprends
monsieur on en veut pas nous on essaie
d'apporter au maximum mais tout le monde
ne comprend pas qu'on essaie de faire ce
qu'on peut quoi à l'origine du désastre
une petite rivière donc là-bas au bout
vous avait la rivière de la elle était
carrément sortie de son lit la qui coule
au fond du jardin de sabineer le niveau
d'eau a carrément dépassé le petit muret
que que vous voyez ici j'ai tout perdu
quoi comme vous voyez j'ai eu beaucoup
d'eau dans ma maison à peu près
1,70 voz l'eau est monté jusqu'ici à peu
près je loge un peu chez des amis je
loge aussi dans la famille comme Sabine
Clément Bertelot habite aujourd'hui chez
des amis sa rue entièrement sinistrée et
désormais déserte après les crues de
novembre la trè inondation survenue
début janvier lui a donné le coup de
grâce en fait on recommence totalement à
zéro euh au niveau de tout he que ça
soit assurance expert ou autre parce que
bah c'est une nouvelle société de
nettoyage parce que la première ne veut
plus venir c'est un nouvel expert les
experts sont débordés ont pris plein de
dossiers et et puis bah c'est assez
compliqué son assurance va payer le
crédit de sa maison pendant 1 an mais
pas au-delà or sans avis de l'expert les
travaux ne peuvent pas démarrer Clément
c'est déjà qu'il ne pourra pas tenir ce
délai j'en suis déjà à 5 6 mois de perdu
pour l'instant donc normalement je
devrais rentrer dans ma maison en
janvier mais j'y serai pas en attendant
les indemnisations Monsieur le Maire
doit gérer l'urgence il a au moins une
soixantaine de famille à reloger il est
nécessaire que il puissent se poser un
petit peu pour réfléchir pour la suite
on sait que leurs maisons sont
inhabitable il faut que les enfants
puissent continuer à aller à l'école et
au collège le gérant de ce camping a mis
à disposition des bingalot aux habitants
sinistrés Sandrine prudom y a trouvé
refuge avec sa fille et une amie dans
l'attente d'une solution de plus long
terme ça suit son cours nous on a
actionné tout ce qu'on pouvait les
enfants ils sont perdus ils se demandent
tous les jours mais on va être où le
mois prochain ma fille qu'elle en plein
brevet et elle craque tous les jours
tous les jours elle pleure ça non mais
moi j'en ai même perdu mon sourire quoi
à l'Hôtel de Ville benoirt Roussel
réunit ses chefs de service avec cette
fois malgré tout une bonne nouvelle la
commune va recevoir du renfort on va
avoir la visite sur la commune de la
mairie de Saint-Amant les eau pendant 3
jours il va avoir 11 agents qui vont
être mobilisés chaque jour de quoi aider
au nettoyage des 21 bâtiments municipaux
inutilisable parmi lesquels plusieurs
écoles une salle de spectacle ou encore
ce bâtiment de 1000 m Carr il abritait
une école de musique et risque d'être
rasé on a un pont alors là c'était
visible il penchait d'un côté donc on l'
l'a fermé tout de suite et puis on a
fait le nécessaire pour le détruire mais
ça nous a pris 2 mois et ça va nous
reprendre presque 4 mois pour le
reconstruire la reconnaissance d'état de
catastrophe naturelle devrait faciliter
les indemnisations des travaux d'urgence
de nettoyage des cours d'eau et de
consolidation des berges doivent éviter
un nouveau
désastre face à ces cru à répétition
quel avenir pour les quartiers
inondables on en débat avec
Jean-François rappin bonsoir bienvenue
vous êtes sénateur l l'air du P calis
Françoise BIM bonsoir et bienvenue vous
êtes climatologue directrice de
recherche à l'Intitut de recherche pour
le développement Éric Daniel Lacombe
bonsoir et bienvenue architecte
spécialiste des risques naturels et des
constructions en zonees inondable et
docteur en urbanisme évidemment Mathieu
croissand et rester à mes côtés
jean-françis rappin vous êtes en en lien
je crois quasi quotidien ou quotidien
avec les les élus de céville inondé
comment ils vont aujourd'hui assez mal
assez mal pour certains parce que
certains ont encore les pieds dans l'eau
euh j'étais dit dimanche une marche
bleue avec les
sinistrés et quelques élus et on sent
très bien que une forme de colère monte
parce que la durée de l'événement est
incroyable c'est-à-dire que depuis le 7
novembre jusqu'à aujourd'hui et encore
demain et encore dans les semaines à
venir on on va rencontrer cette
situation qui est qui est vraiment
désastreuse j'habite mon département
depuis toujours et de mémoire je nai
jamais connu un événement aussi
dramatique aussi dramatique pourquoi
parce que en fait c'est l'étendue de
l'événement qui est considérable le
nombre de villes et de villages le
nombre de villes de villages les bassins
les plusieurs bassins hydrographiques
qui ont été qui ont été touchés quatre
bassins hydrographiques avec à peu près
100 km de long puisque ça remonte
jusqu'au nord sur une cinquantaine de
kilomètres de large donc c'est une
superficie considérable tiens François
une question là-dessus sur les c'est
effectivement rare qu'autant de bassins
hydr soit touché en même temps sur une
période aussi longue alors oui là il y a
eu l'étendue géographique et puis
l'étendue temporelle mais surtout les
volume de pluie hein qui ont été
exceptionnels d'abord en novembre à
certains endroits on a atteint 280 mm de
pluie sur 10 jour alors je rappelle 1 mm
de plusie c'est 1 L par mètre carré donc
ça c'est vraiment des pluies
exceptionneles et puis en en décembre on
a eu à nouveau des pluies cette fois-ci
pas exceptionnelle importante mais pas
exceptionnelle mais par contre elles
sont tombées sur des sols complètement
détrempé et donc ça a encore aggravé la
situation le le GC estime que
l'intensité des épisodes de cru augmente
de 7 % à chaque degrés de réchauffement
supplémentaire donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut se préparer à vivre des événements
comme celui-là parce que malheureusement
pour l'instant on est à 1 et demi hein
de de de réchauffement par rapport aux
objectifs donc il faut se préparer à
avoir d'autres événements du même oui
bien bien sûr on sait que les pluies
torrentielles vont augmenter et c'est ce
que vous avez dit à chaque fois que
notre atmosphère se réchauffe de 1°gr
elle peut contenir 7 % en plus de vapeur
d'eau donc quand on a un événement
météorologique qui vient refroidir cette
atmosphère elle peut plus garder cette
eau et donc elle elle la rejette en
quelque sorte sous forme de pluie et
donc les volumes de pluies augmentent
euh je dirais presque pour une même
tempête que l'on aurait connu il y a 20
ans ou il y a 5 an ou il y a pas
forcément plus de tempêtes mais elles
vont a observe non on n observe pas
davantage de tempêtes on observe pas des
tempêtes plus intenses on voit pas non
plus de changement dans leur trajectoire
par contre il y a deux conséquences des
tempêtes qui vont être beaucoup plus
importantes avec le changement
climatique on en a parler c'est le
volume des puits et puis c'est aussi
pour les régions littorales les
submersions marines qui vont être
aggravé par la hausse du niveau des m je
j'espère qu'on aura le temps d'évoquer
effectivement cette question des des
littorals é Daniel la comombe la la si
on reste dans le Pas de calis la prise
de conscience face au risque inondation
elle est quand même pas nouvelle dans la
région on peut la dater de quand d'après
vous en fait la règle c'est qu'on on
s'appuie sur le dernier alléa connu on
peut dire qu'ici c'est 2002 oui et
c'était à peu près ce qu'on appelle une
une cinquantenale pour le dire vite ça
fait 50 cm d'eau et et les gens étaient
préparés à ça alors ça fait 21 ans que
ça s'est pas passé et et du coup
qu'est-ce qu'on se dit c'est que avec ce
qui se passe plus d'eau dans une cuvette
et bloqué par la mer où il y aura aussi
plus de mer parce qu'il a la montée des
EAU de la mer ça veut dire que tout le
monde est dépassé je comprends la colère
dont parle Jean-François rappin mais la
colère elle a engagé y compris la
prévention qui malgré tout avait été
faite durant ces 20 ça a évolué en en 20
ans la prévtionou en gros quand j'écoute
le président
on devrait faire comme çavait faire les
anciens je pense que c'est une bonne
idée mais ça suffira pas parce que ce
que Savit faire les anciens ça tient je
vous le dis jusqu'à une côte de crue de
2002 50 cm là il faut passer 1 m et donc
à un moment il faut inventer des choses
nouvelles 2002 Mathieu il faut peut-être
dire un mot quand même vous vous
souvenez je souv de lonel Jospin très
très mal accueilli la rumeur d'abville
la rumeur d'abville rumur d'AV on est en
avril 2 2001 et il y a des inondations
notamment in de la Somme et une rumeur
parce que les gens ne comprennent pas
sont débordés le Premier ministre met du
temps à intervenir et une rumeur va ître
à à ville relayé par la population mais
aussi par certains élus locaux selon
laquelle pour préserver Paris on aurait
vidé le surplu de la scène via le canal
du Nord dans tout le bassin de la Somme
et lonel josp va pourtant essayer de
mobiliser des arguments rationnel pour
expliquer aux gens que ça n'est pas
possible on va convoquer des ingénieurs
qui ça n'existe pas les gens vont y
croire il y a un petit rapport Paris
provovince et pu oublié relégué et des
gens dont on s'était pas occupé alors
que François viimu c'est c'est plutôt
dans la nature des sols qu'il faut aussi
aller chercher une autre une autre
explication si on essaie de caractériser
ce qui est en train de se passer oui je
pense que c'est important de dire que
ces inondations elles sont multifacteur
donc il y a l'appui he ça c'est sûr on
en a parlé après cette pluie elle tombe
sur un sol donc il y a l'état du sol si
vous avez un sol qui est imperméable ça
peut être une imperméabilité naturelle
les argiles par exemple sont des sols
imperméables ça peut être une
imperméabilité du à l'urbanisation à la
bétonnisation donc là vous avez deux
solutions si c'est plat l'eau tombe elle
s'accumule et puis si vous êtes là ça
s'appelle une plaine inondable vous êtes
inondé s'il y a une petite pente l'eau
va ruisseler vers les points bas vers
les cours d'eau à force de ruisseler les
cours d'eau vont déborder et les cours
d'eau peuvent déborder loin en fait de
la de l'événement de pluie torrentielle
et puis le le la la dernier le dernier
aspect quand même c'est l'aménagement du
territoire c'est-à-dire que si vous avez
des personnes des activités des biens
des bâtiments publics et privés qui sont
exposés dans ces zones inondables et
bien on parle des inondations s'il y a
personne on en parle pas alors ça
évidemment ce sera un chapitre important
de ce débat Jean-François rappin deux
cru majeurs enfin de c'est presque une
crue qui n'en finit pas là pendant 3
mois avec une tempête avant je voudrais
qu'on parle de la prise de conscience de
de l'évolution du du du du réchauffement
climatique est-ce que ça existait déjà
dans votre région mais est-ce que
maintenant plus personne met ça en doute
ça existait déjà dans notre région
d'autant plus que j'aiétais maire d'une
commune littorale donc sur sur ce
territoire et donc avec cette
sensibilité bien sûr de de l'érosion
côtière de de de la montée naturelle des
EAU du réchauffement climatique c'est
c'est indéniable la prise de conscience
elle est aussi aujourd'hui sur la
constructibilité des territoires
c'est-à-dire comment on évalue qu'un
territoire va être en zone de PPRI c'est
un terme technique mais en fait c'est
finalement est en zone inondable ou pas
et et comment on évalue et comment on
adapte peut-être l'habitat parce qu'il
faut pas se dire qu'un jour ou l'autre
on ne construirait plus forcément sur
ces zones mais comment on adapteraititat
et là on a
des voà est-ce qu'il faut raser ces
quartiers ce que je sais aujourd'hui
parce que il y avait l'état d'esprit
bien sûr des élus mais il y a l'état
d'esprit des sinistrés enfin on voit des
situations qui sont dramatiques de gens
qui ne veulent plus rentrer dans leur
maison parce qu'ils ont subi en 15 jours
deux inondations après s'être
reconstruit et à partir de là eux ils
ont une réelle conscience c'est de se
dire nous on veut plus rentrer là parce
que on met notre vie en danger juste
j'ajoute nous avons eu dans ce grand
malheur beaucoup de chance c'est que les
inondations et la montée des EAU rapides
c'est faite le jour si ça avait été la
nuit je crois que le bilan humain aurait
été dramatique parce que en fait la
solidarité a fonctionné les MRES les
agriculteurs ont sorti les tracteurs ont
sorti les gens de chez eux il y a une
solidarité les pompiers bien sûr tous
les services de l' ça mais mais la
conscience elle elle est prise en fait à
chaque épisode dramatique mais celui-là
particulièrement dramatique d'ailleurs
le ministre a fait des annonces hier sur
le rachat potentiel de maison oui on va
en parler alors ça c'est effectivement
l'adaptabilité la question de
l'indemnisation on va en parler aussi
mais je vrais rester encore un peu dans
le constat pour sortir du du du pas de
calis pour voir que habiter en zone
idondable finalement ça concerne
beaucoup de français et puisamoc qui
plane audessus de la tête de 17 millions
de Français selon le ministère de la
transition écologique ça fait un
français sur 4 François Hume est-ce que
avec la l'intensité plus forte des
épisodes de plus il y a de plus en plus
de Français en zone inondable al c'est
une bonne question aujourd'hui c'est un/
qu
et quand on regarde les les plans des
risques ville par ville c'est basé sur
ce qu'on a connu et ce qu'on connaît
c'est rarement basé sur ce qui va se
passer dans les 20 prochaines années les
50 prochaines années et donc il y aura
certainement dans 50 ans beaucoup plus
de zones inondables ça c'est clair
d'accord juste pour
est-ce que Paris est inondable ah bah
bien sûr vous rappelez en 1910 1910
depuis depuis la fameuse cru 19 bien sûr
Paris est inondable d'ailleurs en en
2016 il y a encore eu des des
inondations et on n'est pas à l'abri que
ça se répète hein on n'est pas préparé
l'adaptation de l'habitat ERC Daniel
laacbe c'est vraiment votre votre
domaine on donc ça veut dire on peut
construire dans des zones inondables
aujourd'hui a il y a des permis il y a
des projets ça existe bien sûr oui oui
il faut deux choses il faut quand même
un un accord mais je pense qu'il y a un
point de démarche il faut un accord
entre le niveau local et le niveau
d'État c'est-à-dire que j'ai pas réussi
une opération si j'avais pas un préfet
dans la main et un maire dans l'autre
sinon on y arrive pas et ce que je
disais tout à l'heure où tout le monde a
crié en disant c'est la faute de tout le
monde les canaux sont pas entretenus en
gros chacun disait c'est toi qui est
responsable on VO la balle quoi ouais
malgré tout le PPRI c'est dire il y a
des endroits on construira plus voyez il
y a plus de gens aujourd'hui en 2023
qu'il avait en 2002 et qui avait au 19e
siècle dans le Pas de Calais dans ces
endroits o on ne construira plus vous
dites là il faut ça c'est une décision
moi je peux faire des dessins après il y
a des arbitrages c'est ce qu'on appelle
la politique mais la première chose
c'est que par exemple quand les vallées
l'accident d'Alex arrive en 2022 donc la
tempête Alex 2022 les TR avec plein de
morts là c'est un préfet Xavier PEL qui
est désigné par le Président de la
République je l'accompagne pendant 2 ans
pour justement se dire où est-ce qu'on
doit construire ou pas alors c'est plus
simple dans une vallée comme Alex dire
que la la la tempête elle a rasé
elle-même toutes les maisons c'est que
les rochers ont emporté les maisons là
les maisons sont toujours là ce qui fait
une différence ici il y a une autre
différence qui est tout à fait
intéressante c'est que celui qui a eu la
mission de cette responsabilité c'est le
maire de Saint-Omer François De Coster
et je pense que ça c'est quelque chose
de tout à fait singulier à à à spécifier
c'est comme si l'État c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure assure la
prévention de la cinquantenale on va
dire des 50 cm et c'est un maire qui
doit avec l'ensemble de sa
connaissanceire fabriquer la deuxième
marche à franchir parce qu'on pourrait
se dire l'état d'ailleurs certains
demandent ça vous nous avez amené à 50
avec les ligues emmenez-nous à 1 m
emmenz-nous 1,50 et puis à la fin du
siècle on sera où alors que les
Hollandais que De Coster va visiter
depuis 2004 ils ont inventé un programme
alors qu'ils avaient inventé les PO d'
pour dire vite c'est ce qu'on a c'estàd
des creux boss casi mais au moment quand
les casiers sont plein ils s'évacu plus
et bien les Hollandais ont commencé à
rendre des terres à la mer alors
évidemment là dans le Pas de Calais je
te regarde Jean-François les terres
qu'il faudrait rendre à la mer c'est le
foncier de la rétention il appartient
essentiellement aux agriculteurs leur
demander quelque chose en ce moment pe
pas la bonne pe ça semble compliqué
Jean-François rappin on on a construit
dans ces zones imidondal mais est-ce
qu'il y a eu des imprudences voyez ce
que je veux dire est-ce que si on
regarde tout toutes les les zones vous
dites ah là on aurait vraiment pas dû y
aller quoi au regarde de l'événement tel
qu'on le voit aujourd'hui je pense que
il y avait c'était imprévisible de voir
une extension aussi importante de
l'événement d'autant qu'aujourd'hui et
et je le dis aux climatologues et
peut-être aux géologues s'il y en a qui
nous écoutent c'est qu'on a un
phénomène le deuxième effet qui se coule
la remontée des nappes phéatiques
c'est-à-dire qu'on a des nappes
fréatiques qui ne sont pas très profonde
et là on a une remontée donc une
remontée des eau qui qui était
complètement inattendue alors vous dire
aujourd'hui que certains ont commis des
erreurs en terme d'urbanisme ou pas on
va on pourrait chercher des coupables
dans tous les sens on a parlé du curage
des fossé il faut savoir aujourd'hui
qu'un maire quand il a un doute sur un
fossé qui ne s'écoule plus c'est une
procédure qui est abominable à monter
pour pouvoir le faire alors que de
lui-même il pourrait dire j'envoie une
grue je creuse j'enlève les trons
d'arbres qui gênent et et et tout se
passe bien donc je pense que on va pas
chercher qui est coupable on va pas
chercher si le maire qui a été sous
pression pour accorder un permis de
construire l' accordé de façon de de
façon pas anormale parce qu'il y a
toujours un contrôle de légalité mais
l'a fait peut-être de façon imprudente
je pense qu'on on en est pas là
aujourd'hui c'est dire comment on fait
pour que ça ne se reproduise plus
l'événement climatique il se reproduira
mais comment on fait pour ne pas avoir
cette situation de catastrophe vous
faites le lien entre entre les
inondations et la colère des
agriculteurs oui parce que le refrain du
moment c'est Aro sur les normes les
agriculteur s'en plaignent alors souvent
a raison parce que il faut le dire ils
ont une avalanche de règles à respecter
c'est difficile quand vous êtes pas
juriste et en plus quand vous passez 70
he par semaine à faire tourner votre
exploitation les Français les abords les
normes il considèrent que qu'elles sont
des entraves à le liberté même le
président de la République dans sa
dernière conférence de presse semblait
leur emboitter le pas en appelant son
gouvernement à mettre fin à supprimer
des normes à mettre fin à ce qu'il
appelait ses complexités qui décourage à
prener au fond la France du bon sens
plutôt que la France des tracas sur un
air bien connu hein celui de georgees
Pompidou arrêtons d'emmerder les
Français oui là les normes les règles
elles ont aussi un intérêt elles sont
aussi là pour protéger elles sont aussi
là pour prémunir pour prévenir et en
particulier dans le cas qui nous occupe
ce soir ben ça peut servir hein dans les
zones inondables les normes et quand
certains s'en affranchissent ou
lorsqu'on affaire à des crus hors norme
pour le coup et ben le premier et le
seul réflexe c'est toujours de se
retourner vers qui ben vers l'état c'est
la schizophrénie de l'époque hein à
l'heure du citoyen consommateur qui veut
voir toujours tous ses droits garantis
euh avec le moins possible de règles
voors je pense pas qu'Emmanuel Macron
quand il a parlé lors de sa conférence
de presse pensait précisément aux normes
en vigueur dans les zones inondables
mais pas lui faire ce procè il est
arrivé dans un passé récent qu'un de s
un de ses prédécesseurs y pense c'était
Nicolas Sarkozi le 20 avril 2009 à
l'occasion d'un discours sur le Grand
Paris il appelait ainsi à ou guillemets
changer nos procédures notre façon
d'appliquer le droit sortir du respect
passif d'une réglementation de plus en
plus pesante donc ça on est dans la même
musique quand même et puis il invité
même à déréglementer et à rendre
constructible ZES inonda pour les
bâtiments adaptés à l'environnement et
au risque un an plus tard machine
arrière de la part de Chantel Jouano qui
dit il faudrait arrêter absolument de
construire dans ces zones là pourquoi
ben la tempête cythia était passé par là
alors ça m'intéresse d'entendre votre
réaction é Daniel Lacombe là-dessus
puisque est-ce que
effectivement ça peut sembler paradoxal
de dire ça ce soir mais il y a des des
endroits parce que c'est du cas par cas
où on pourrait finalement décider que
certes c'est une zone inendable mais on
peut y construire ouais ça dire que
c'est ça l'arbitrage qui qu'il faut
prendre vous savez que j'ai construit à
romorentin le pour l'instant le seul
quartier qui résistait à une crue d'
1,50 100 dégâ dans une zone inondable
mais on avait quand même gardé 80 % de
la surface pour la rivière mais c'était
une crûlante et surtout c'est pas comme
ici enfin ici je vous regarde vous dans
le Pas de calis l'eau peut pas ressortir
quand je suis à Mandelieu c'est une crue
rapide donc c'està dire que l'eau elle
s'échappe très vite et là c'est
l'inverse on décide de pas construire et
au contraire de calmer l'eau quand je
suis dans les vallées c'est danger de
mort on dira un mot tout à l'heure sur
les indemnisations par la loi le fond
Barnier en fait c'est une indemnisation
quand vous risquez votre vie c'estd que
si vous restez dans la rivière vous
partez avec la maison donc la première
des questions je suis d'accord avec
Jean-François faisons pas la morale et
je pense qu'on a passé la marche 2002
2020 sur les 50 antenales on a un niveau
de protection un niveau de prévention
c'est comme si on avait un bien commun
qui était là il faut passer la marche
d'après et être créatif donc évidemment
qu'on va pas augmenter l'urbanisation je
pense que c'est raisonnable et après à
tous ceux qui disent faut monter les
digues moi je viens de vous répondre que
j'y croyais pas et à ceux qui disent
faut enlever les maisons si j'ai enlevé
les 160 maisons de la vésué
Jean-François il démarre comment en
disant que c'est un territoire tellement
vaste avec quatre bassin versant vous
croyez Thomas H qu'on va enlever toutes
les maisons donc en fait il faut trouver
une nouvelle idée il y a déjà des
territoires en France c'est pas loin ça
fera plaisir à Christophe Béchu à
l'ouest d'Anger il y a déjà des
territoires où ils ont appris à étancher
les maisons à vivre avec l'inondation et
à résister c'est ça qu'il faut passer
toutes vos images concrètement ça c'est
les maisons où l'eau rentre pas je sa
donc en fait toutes les images montrent
que les gens on disons des bottes et les
pompiers ont des cuissardes les gens ont
des voitures et les pompiers ont des
bateaux les les les gens ont des
fenêtres et quand vous êtes en Floride
vous appelez un étancheur quand l'alerte
de la tempête arrive et vous étanchez la
maison donc je pense qu'il faudrait
étancher tous les rez-de-chaussée et on
saurait le faire rentrer par l'étage et
à ce moment-là on pourrait continuer
habiter y compris faire du ramassage
scolaire dans ces quartiers alors vous
l'évoquiez raser les quartiers racheter
les maisons pour permettre au aux
habitants propriétaire de de s'en sortir
bah ça fait partie de de des annonces
qui ont été faites par le ministre
Christophe Béchu hier on va parler de
l'indemnisation tout de suite avec
Jonathan du Priz qui est qui est dans
les coulisses de ce sens public cette
délicate question rebonsoir Jonathan de
l'indemnisation des sinistré du Nord et
du pas decalais par l'État donc quelques
avancées on peut dire ça on l'impression
que ça P un peu effectivement hier soir
il y avait l'inauguration du premier
comité de suivi des inondations à la
préfecture d'aras où s'est rendu le
ministre de la transition écologique
Christophe béchux il a fait des annonces
très attendu à la fois par les élus et
aussi évidemment par les sinistrés qui
sont à boudner il a annoncé alors
plusieurs choses notamment la mise en
place d'un guichet unique dans les
préfectures pour l'aide financière des
artisans des commerçants qui sont
impactés le maintien des pompes aussi
longtemps que nécessaire dit-il dans les
zones encore sous les EAU autre annonce
également c'est le classement de nouvell
commune en état de catastrophe naturelle
ça ça va permettre en fait de simplifier
l'indemnisation pour nombre de sinistrés
et la principale annonce c'est que le
ministre a ouvert la porte à un rachat
par l'état de certaines habitations des
sinistrés écoutez le ministre il était
au micro de nos confrères de BFM
littoral vous êtes en particulier vous
avez subi des dégâts qui dépassent la
moitié de la valeur vénale de votre
maison vous êtes éligible à un rachat
automatique par l'État qui se fait dans
la limite de 240000 € d'argent public
vous avez subi des dégâts mais à cette
hauteur et vous êtes dans une zone qui a
été inondée à ce moment-là vous pouvez
demander un rachat amiable qui nécessite
qu'il y a un accord entre l'État et la
collectivité locale ça fait partie des
choses qu'on précisera au cours de ces
prochaines semaines mais on a déjà
précisé aujourd'hui les règles pour ce
qui concerne ceux dont les dégâts ont
dépassé 50 % de la valeur vénale du bien
alors autre nouvelle importante pour les
les sinistri du pcalais le fond Barnier
il va pouvoir être activé pour ses cru
on va faire un peu de pédagogie de quoi
on parle de quoi s'agit-il alors avant
de vous je reprends la phrase avant de
ou
maisâsp la laurale bien pour bénéfer
dispositif de rachat dans le cadre du
fond Barnier et donc qu'est-ce que c'est
le fond Barnier et ben en fait c'est un
fond de prévention des risques naturels
majeurs ça a été créé en 95 c'est un
fond de 200
million mich Barni voilàte le fond porte
son nom il permet en fait
l'expropriation de bien exposé à un
risque naturel prévisible ça peut être
des glissements de terrain des
avalanches des crus torentiel
que ces risques menacent gravement des
vies humaines or dans le cas de ces cru
il y avait une sorte de de doute qui
planait car contrairement aux tempê Alex
dont vous avez parlé précédemment ou
xintiia ces inondations elles n'ont fait
aucune victime et donc elles auraient pu
ne pas tomber sous le coup de ce ce fond
mais le fondbni ne résout pas non plus
tous les problèmes et vous allez écouter
ce maire le maire d'c dans le Pas de
calis et bien il y a encore beaucoup de
pain sur la planche malgré ce fond
écoutez-le fond Barnier ça peut prendre
plusieurs années à mettre en œuvre et la
grosse difficulté c'est d'apporter la
preuve qu'on ne peut plus rien faire
pour sauvegarder les bâtiments et
protéger les habitants c'est veà dire
plus de mesure possible pour en amont ou
en aval pour essayer de les de les
protéger et puis surtout la
problématique c'est qu'on n pas le droit
de reconstruire et ici on est en
centre-ville donc je me vois pas raser
des rues en centre-ville et laisser des
terrains vagues le but c'est d'être
résilient c'est de faire en sorte qu'on
on puisse peut-être racheter des biens
les raser et puis puis finalement mettre
un étage faire un rez-de-chaussée garage
et puis peut-être des habitations à
l'étage mais il faut être résilient il
faut avancer et pour ça on a besoin
d'être aidé et avec des leviers qui sont
beaucoup plus souples que le fond Barni
et dans les solutions avancées par
Christophe Béchu he du très court terme
aussi hein c'est pour reloger tous ces
sinistrés qui ne peuvent plus être chez
eux il a annoncé une centaine de
mobilehom financé par un fond d'aide au
logement et on voit bien que l'urgence
s'éternise un petit peu Thomas dans le
Nord et dans le Pas de Calais où 450000
personnes ont été tout touché par ses
cru merci beaucoup Jonathan
Jean-François rappin le le rachat des
des des maisons par l'État il y a y a il
y a quelques quelques riverins dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure qui qui
n'attendent que ça en fait qui je ve pas
rentrer chez Mo c'est encore dimanche
quand on a reçu ce collectif après la
marche qui qui disait mais moi si l'état
me donne une somme pour revendre ma
maison même à perte je je je revends ma
maison je revends ma maison parce que
les gens sont tellement apurés d'abord
et puis puis déprimés de de de la
situation qui sont qui sont prêts à
quitter à quitter leur leur logement
dans temps et je reviens juste sur la
photo là on parlait éventuellement
d'erreur d'urbanisme ou autre mais je
crois que les maisons qui sont là elles
ont une cinquantaine d'années et donc si
on avait pu prévoir il y a 50 ans ce qui
allait se passer aujourd'hui ça aurait
été beaucoup plus facile alors
aujourd'hui on a l'expérience physique
de ce qui se passe c'est là où où
peut-être il faut réfléchir à une
nouvell construction moi donc ça veut
dire quoi c'est on va raser ces maisons
et et et construire autre chose à la
place que tout au moins celles qui
seront dans un état déplorable ou
inhabitable euh elles devront être
probablement rasées bien sûr avec la
capacité de de rachat par l'État pour
permettre à ces gens de de se reloger
imaginez-vous je je j'insiste là-dessus
parce que la situation pour les
sinistrés elle est terrible elle est
terrible parce que il faut retrouver des
capacités de logement quasi immédiat
quelquefois c'est des familles avec de
trois enfants capacité de logement
immédiate dans une situation tendue du
logement finalement et là on arrive à
finalement une forme de de de de
cisaillement d'un côté la pression sur
le logement et de l'autre côté la
nécessité de reloger immédiatement des
gens dans des conditions qui sont pas
celles de leur maison l'idée l'idée des
mobilehom dans un premier temps c'est
une bonne chose mais ça n'est absolument
pas durable donc il va falloir se
pencher vraiment très vite sur la
question de la reconstruction de la
réhabil
la réhabilitation pardon de ces
logements et peut-être avec avec des
normes pas des normme j'aime pas le
terme norme mais avec des moyens
différents j'été maire du littoral je
vous l'ai dit et justement quand on
commençait il y a une vaintaine d'années
à parler de ces questions de submersion
moi j'avais posé la question à la DDTM
puisqu'on nous disait il faut plus
construire il faut plus construire il
faut plus oui sauf que à force de plus
vouloir construire on arrive à des
situations compliquées étendu de
logement mais c'était de dire simple
peut-on
réimaginer ne serait-ce que les
interrupteurs les prises électriques au
moins 1 m j'ai une situation je prends 2
minutes pour vous la
décrire dimanche une dame m'interpelle
elle me dit Monsieur Rapin je n'ai pas
votre langage mais je voudrais vous
exposer un fait tout simple notre
compteur néis notre compteur EDF a été
inondé sur la première fois l'assurance
a pris en charge pour la remise en place
du compteur une semaine après un mois
après rebelotte et et la dame dit mettez
mon compteur s'il vous plaît à un autre
endroit si ça recommence et là on lui
dit ah non madame ça coûte 900 €. et
donc la dame dit mais moi j'ai pas les
moyens de faire ça donc si si on se
posait savez ma belle-mère disait
toujours nous ne sommes pas assez riches
pour acheter pas cher bah à un certain
moment il faut dire il faut mettre le
paquet il faut mettre le paquet et puis
se dire comment on peut réinventer des
choses pour cette dame j'ai écrit au
ministre pour lui dire tout simplement
mais Monsieur le Ministre ces situations
là on va les connaître partout
c'est-à-dire comment ne serait-ce que le
compteur électrique qui fournit
l'électricité en situation difficile ça
veut dire que dans la fe de route des
techniciens et dit c c'est intégré
Françoise Vimeux vous avez listé
finalement dans dans dans le constat
voilà la prise de conscience les
solutions l'adaptabilité la la façon de
revoir
finalement comment on construit comment
quel quartier on garde et cetera c'est
une dimension très importante pour vous
oui il y a plusieurs choses d'abord je
pense qu'il faut bien dire aux gens que
ça fait une trentaine d'années
maintenant qu'on sait que les événements
extrêmes comme ces pluis torenciel sont
exacerbés par le changement climatique
donc ça fait 30 ans qu'on peut prévoir à
peu près ce qui va se passer il faut
dire aussi que il y a des habitations
qui sont de facto dans des zones
inondables on entendait dans le
reportage la dame dire voilà il y a il y
a le le petit ruisseau au bout de mon
jardin quand vous avez un ruisseau au
bout de votre jardin vous êtes dans en
zone inondable il y a pas voilà à parler
Pender toutes les maisons qui sont dans
dans ces Z il a millions de Français
concernés sans doute en dessous de la
réalité donc ex alors ce que nous disent
les les experts du JEC qui travaillent
sur l'adaptation c'est ou bien vous
restez et vous vous adaptez si c'est
possible en faisant attention au
maladaptation comme les digues on a vu
ce que ça a donné pendant la tempête
xintia avec une dig qui était pas
dimensionnée ou bien il y a la
relocalisation mais dans les deux cas il
y a des coups la relocalisation ça un
coup psychologique les gens doivent
quitter leur maison de famille par
exemple vous relocalisez des activités
donc des activités professionnelles
c'est un cou économique et social et
puis l'adaptation vous en parlerez
peut-être mieux que moi elle a des
limites on sait aussi que au-delà d'un
certain degré de réchauffement
l'adaptation elle devient complexe voire
impossible dans certains territoires pas
seulement que pour les pluis torrentiels
donc je pense qu'il faut être bien clair
sur ce qu'on est en capacité de faire et
là vous vous êtes certainement mieux
calé que moi et puis bien expliquer
quand même que la question de
l'habitabilité sur certains territoires
elle se pose de en toute rigueur on peut
habiter partout mais ça un coup et Éric
Daniel si on prend on revient dans le
Pas de calis là vraiment on a cette
photo de du derrière vous effectivement
vous nous dites ça c'est sans doute
construit il y a une cinquantaine
d'années ces maisons là bon j'entends
allez on va pas toutes les raser
évidemment c'est absurde et puis ça sera
un coup psychologique en terme de
budgétaire intenable mais qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire comment on peut adapter
une maison ou un quartier qui a été
construit il y a 50 ans alors que les
cru se répète la première des questions
c'est de demander à l'habitant si il
veut rester ou si il veut par partir ou
je pense qu'on fera rien sans l'accord
de l'habitant c'estd que si vous aimez
pas la montagne c'est pas la peine
d'aller à la neige quoi voyez donc si on
n'aime pas l'eau faut changer de
quartier mais les gens qui sont là
vraiment ils aiment ça donc la première
chose c'est ça que je disais l'État peut
faire la prévention mais après
l'adaptation c'est une idée vraiment
originale elle sera faite par les
habitants local les habitants voyez
c'est c'est pour ça que je suis content
que ça soit un mère qui porte ça parce
que c'est le chemin direct vers les
habitants c'est ce que j'appelle un
engagement de responsabilité vous avez
une protection sociale che pas d'avoirre
vie et d'être mare
de qui dit je veux rester fait parce le
fond Barnier c'est très sympa mais il
faut le faire sur quelques petites
choses et puis vraiment vous voyez le
territoire puis là on parle de ça mais
il y a de jours la moitié du Danemark
était aussi inondé après on aura la
Loire Atlantique enfin on va pas
déménager la totalité du monde et on se
dirait le budget du fond barer suffit
pas voilà et à quel prix déjà il est
déjà les assurances et les assurances
vont pas nous suivre il y a deux cas de
figure après ça le premier vous avez vu
c'est on demande oui ou non vous voulez
rester pas un référendum mais c'est
quand même une vraie question parce que
si on s'engage on s'engage lame des
choses si c'est neuf c'est facile là je
suis en train de de démarrer un quartier
Orléan on attend 3 m d'eau bah je
dessine tout de suite le neuf qui est
adapté c'estàdire que je rentre par le
premier étage alors j'essae de mettre au
point avec les industriels des nouveaux
Monds charge des ascenseurs qui
coûteraient pas le prix d'un ascenseur
et au rez-de-chaussée je fais de l'ombre
des préau n'oublions pas aussi que le
dialogue évoluera quand on reviendra aux
périodes de sécheresse et c'est là que
j'irai parlé aux agriculteurs quand
eux-mêmes n'auront plus d'eau pour
irriguer qu'il faudra changer la nature
de la culture et que peut-être ils
remettront les ha pour leur propre
intérêt en gros ça marchera que si
chacun retrouve un intérêt à chaque
raison c'est pour ça que j' c'est du
neuf c'est relativement facile si
c'estancien par exemple ils sont en
train de refaire des écoles il faut les
refaire euh complètement re l'ancien
c'est ce qu'on appelle la réhabilitation
évidemment que les rez-de-chaussée c'est
pas si compliqué dans le pas decalis
quand je suis à Mandelieu je prends 2 m
d'eau à Orléan ça sera 3 et dans les
vallées c'est le rocher qu'emporte la
maison là vous regardez toutes les
photos
je dirais que jusqu'à 1,20 c'est facile
et c'est facile parce qu'il faut
étancher le rez-de-chaussée pendant le
temps de la crue c'estàdire que on a un
temps d'alerte l'intérêt c'est que une
cruante on peut protéger sa maison h du
coup il faut surexploiter les étages
c'estàd qu'on habite au même endroit et
on commence à l'étage ce que tu as dit
Jean-François c'est il y a plus la
chaudière en bas il y a plus les prises
électriques il y a même plus l'escalier
et on vit à l'étage AV avec un rez-
dechaussée qui est étanche pardon mais
la Floride sait faire ça très bien donc
je pense qu'il faut engager des et et le
coût est pas est pas intenable vous
voyez ce que je veux dire la question
moi je suis pas économiste mais c'est à
comparer avec l'autre cûp d'une
démolition complète ouis de trouver des
nouveaux fonciers et du compteur à
mettre 10 fois et du compteur à mettre
10 fois faut changer les habitudes
culturelles et et et ainsi de suite mais
sincèrement quand j'aidé Patrick olier à
préparer l'inondation du Grand Paris je
lui ai dit d'acheter des bateaux enfin
je veux dire on achèterait plein de
bateau on règlerait tout dans le petit
village dont je parle qui est au sud
d'Anger les gars ils savent même faire
en temps de tempête du ramassage
scolaire et les premières heures qu'il
faisaient quand il y avait le bateau il
pensaiit que tout était accessible parce
que la mer enfin l'eau avait recouvert
les champs donc ils ont essayé de couper
en fait ils sont tombés sur les clôtures
évidemment il y a les clôtures des
barbelet donc en fait ce qui est très
marrant c'est qu'en fait quand vous avez
une inondation même avec un bateau vous
reprenez le chemin de la route pour
emmener les enfants à l'école d'
apprenons à vivre avec c'est ça c'est
culturel il il y a la technique et il y
a le C allez dernier chapitre il nous
reste quelques minutes effectivement
parce que vous l'avez évoqué sur les la
question du du littoral on est on est un
pays de de littoral beaucoup de communes
qui sont menacées par les conséquences
du réchauffement climatique justement on
va écouter le le ministre de la
transition écologique sur ce thème
Christophe béchou qui était à souslac
sur mer c'était au mois de novembre
dernier écoutons il y a au travers de ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui une vision liée
au réchauffement climatique de ce que la
montée des eaux l'érosion du trait de
côte va projeté dans plein d'autres
endroits du littoral français il y a en
fonction de ce que sera la réal du
réchauffement climatique jusqu'à 50000
habitations logement
jusqu'à 750 entreprises qui vont être
concerné à un titre ou un autre des
dizaines de kilomètres d'infrastructure
qui vont être d'ici la fin de ce siècle
concerné par cette érosion du trait de
côte Françoise Vimeux scénario à plus de
degrés c'est c'est quoi c'est des côtes
françaises qui vont forcément reculer
c'est de ça dont on parle érosion du
trait cô ça veut dire ça oui alors en
France on est sur des scénarios qui nous
emmènent à un réchauffement plus 4°grés
à la fin du siècle he donc ça fait un
peu moins de
3°grés à horizon 2050 donc si on fait
rien non justement si on tient les
engagements qui ont été réalisés dans
les cops c'est pas certain que tout le
monde au niveau international
arrive rir ses engagements ah bah on on
va on est sur des trajectoires qui vont
vers plus 4 degrés ça pourrait
éventuellement être plus à la fin du
siècle donc il faut bien dimensionner
l'adaptation le le recul du trait côte
l'érosion c'est un phénomène naturel qui
est aggravé par le changement climatique
c'est un phénomène qui est pas linéaire
il progresse par à coup et je crois
qu'il y a une soixantaine de communes en
France où le le recul du trait de côte
Est de plusieurs mètres par an à fécand
par exemple l'année dernière on a eu des
éboulements des falaises qui étaient
absolument impressionnant avec des
maisons qui étaient quand même assez
loin et finalement qui se retrouvent au
bord donc c'est il y a vraiment quelque
chose de de très impression
et bien sûr on comprend bien que le
changement climatique vient aggraver ça
à la fois quand il y a des tempêtes mais
aussi de manière chronique lors des
grandes marées ça on en parle beaucoup
moins hein des inondations chroniques
pendant les grandes marées et l'autre
effet c'est que ça vient saliniser en
fait certains aquifères qu'on on utilise
sur leslit les aquifè c'est alors c'est
l'eau qui est souterraine qui peut être
plus ou moins en profondeur selon
l'endroit où on est hein vous l'avez dit
dans le pas decalé il y a beaucoup
d'aquifères qui sont juste en dessous de
la surface et donc les nappes peuvent
remonter très facilement quand elles
sont pleines et puis ce qui est
important de dire c'est que quand on a
des inondations comme là on a connu et
bien les cours d'eau et même les nappes
ont du mal à s'évacuer vers la mer à
marée haute donc ça ralentit
l'évacuation des EAU ça explique aussi
l'extension dans la durée des
inondations Jean-François rappin les les
quelles sont les conséquences de cette
érosion du trait de côte dans dans le
Pas de Calais il y a il y a déjà des des
quartiers qui il y a des endroits il y a
des endroits qui sont identifiés comme
alors quartiers qui disparaissent non
non on a eu l'utilisation il y a
quelques années du fond Barnier sur la
commune d'quien je me souviens des des
maisons étai finalement à 30 40 m de la
du bord de la falaise mais justement
pour prévoir qu'un jour elle
s'écroulerait le fondbarnier a était
déclenché je péachet mais l'État a
racheté ses maisons mais avec il les
rachète à un bon prix tiens d'ailleurs
elles avaient été racheté au prix du
marché je pense il y avait j'avais pas
entendu de la part des propriétaires et
métant attaché à ce dossier
particulièrement qui qui a eu des
problèmes mais je je reviens simplement
quelques minutes sur ce qui a été dit
finalement l'érosion du trait de côte
les phénomènes côtiers les phénomènes
climatiques violents et la remontée des
eaux dans les fleuves nécessite aussi
parce que c'est important il y a une
marée haute mais il y a aussi une marée
basse et à marée basse on peut avoir un
effet de chasse qui entretient aussi les
fossées et les les fleuves naturellement
et je pense que dans les phénomènes
qu'on voit là on a peut-être aussi une
réflexion avoir sur une plus grande
facilité je le disais en début de propos
pour entretenir les les entretenir les
cours d'eau euh pouvoir pouvoir le faire
de façon beaucoup plus pragmatique par
on parlait des normes tout à l'heure là
il y en a trop ah mais oui non c'est
c'est surtout c'est c'est la complexité
des procédures ouais c'est la complexité
des procédures il faut pouvoir les
simplifier moi je fais les cérémonies du
en ce moment dans les communes qui sont
concernées les maires disent à l'état
permettez-nous et au législateur de fait
aussi permettez-nous d'avoir des
procédures plus simplifiées on va pas
faire n'importe quoi on doit respecter
la biodiversité ceci dit quand on voit
ça je sais pas comment la biodiversité
elle va s'en s'en ressortir parce qu'on
va avoir une érosion des sols on va
avoir un tas de choses qui vont qui vont
se découvrir dans les semaines dans les
mois et peut-être dans les années à
venir et donc il faut un certain
pragmatisme pour l'entretien de tous ces
de tous ces ces territoires et pour le
trait de côte c'est c'est à peu près
pareil avec cette notion peut-être de de
de d'urbaniser différemment euh pour
pour pour accuser les coups de boutoir
de de la mer et du vent un mot rapide
pardon n interrompre mais il nous reste
vraiment très peu de temps on n pas du
tout parlé euh on a évoqué les
indemnisations et cetera vous vous vous
demandez que le gouvernement sollicite
les fonds européens c'esto ou demandé je
l'ai demandé très tôt hein euh à la
première tempête quasi immédiatement
j'avais j'avais sollicité les différents
ministères pour que on met en place très
vite les fonds européens à la fois
d'urgence mais aussi le fond de
solidarité de l'Union européenne qui
existe qui a déjà été déclenché dans
certains états le seul problème c'est
qu'il faut un niveau de travaux et de
dégradation qui soit très important en
gros pour la région nordpcalais parce
qu'on parle encore de la région
nordpcalais dans dans dans ses fonds de
cohésion c'est 1 milliard 7 alors de
dégâts 1 milliard 7 de dégâts pour
pouvoir enclencher ce ce fond euh ce
fond de solidarité de l'Union européenne
je j'espère et le gouvernement je pense
sur les sollicitation a fait le travail
qu'on pourra déclencher ce fond et puis
il y a un fond d'urgence aussi et aussi
un élément important qui est celui de du
déclenchement de la sécurité civile
européenne on y a eu droit mais je crois
aussi que la France par rapport à des
événements comme ceuxl doivent s'équiper
c'est pas normal qu'on fasse venir des
pompes de capacité
depuis les pays de l'est parce qu'on a
pas en France de disponible un bilan
tiens sur ce qui s'est passé tempête
Alex les Trois Vallées là en ALP
maritime c'est pas une colle mais
combien ça a coûté est-ce qu'il y a eu
des fonds européens justement pour pour
venir en aide je pense qu'on parler d'un
milliard sur sur la prês Alex le fond
Barnier a pas dépensé cette somme là
mais il y a eu d'autres fonds je sais
pas s'ils sont européen ou mais il y a
eu ce qu'on a appelé un fond de la
reconstruction qui n'a pas été à
l'identique puisquil y avait danger
mortel oui on n pas reconstruit
l'identique évidment alors alors qu'ici
Jean-François dit un dernier mot très
important c'est que j'ai l'impression
c'est pour ça que je pense qu'on a fait
un progrès depuis 2002 c'est que il y a
moins de gens qui parlent de on va dire
d'infrastructure technique et plus de
régulation naturelle donc ça va aller
dans le sens de la biodiversité de la
nature et je pense que ça c'est le
chemin vous voyez je le dis les
habitants et peut-être que la nature va
peut-être aussi nous aider à passer ces
prémisses de de de grandes catastrophes
humanitair hein c'est c'est presque ça
qui est montré au pas de calis ouais
c'est de ça dont on parle aussi merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat Jia à bientôt sur Public
Sénat c'est la fin de cette émission
rendez-vous demain 18h 22h pour un
nouveau sens public et puis noter que
l'invité de la matinale demain matin
face à Oriane monsign an Genevard la
secrétaire générale du parti LR les
républicains bonne
soirée